hola soy únicas que hoy cumple 28 años
soy periodista especializada en
sexualidad
y era adicta a ligar mientras cargaba
me instalé por primera vez una
aplicación para ligar hará unos cinco
años más o menos y se abrió un mundo de
repente podía elegir si me gustaba una
persona o no me gustaba entre fotos en
tailandia y frases inspiracionales jamás
ligar había sido tan fácil
me tardé mucho en hacer match con
alguien no me acuerdo de su nombre no sé
si se llamaba guillermo o paula pero da
igual porque todos mis encuentros se
regían por el mismo patrón
quedábamos tomábamos algo rápido me daba
igual su mente porque necesitaba su
cuerpo
y vamos a su casa nos quitamos la ropa
a veces había algo de sexo oral pocas
veces fue placentero
penetración rápida orgasmo fingido y
listo
esas noches
yo no tenía sexo con alguien
yo me masturbaba con su cuerpo era una
gran consumidora de personas
viví la llamada cultura juca o dicho de
otro modo el aquí te pillo aquí te
empotró
algo caracterizado por la inmediatez de
los encuentros la poca implicación en el
sexo y en el amor
el aumento de las infecciones de
transmisión sexual
y la poca estabilidad de las relaciones
porque total si tengo a miles de
personas en la aplicación y si ésta no
es la persona
fueron pasando los encuentros y me
empecé a sentir vacía y no entendía muy
bien por qué
así que me compré un solucionador de
clítoris y ahí se abrió otro mundo podía
tener orgasmos en 60 segundos para
orgasmo
y mis días pasaban entre
bueno me masturbaba una vez al día como
mínimo y únicamente le dedicaba dos
minutos nadie nunca me había dado tanto
placer en tan poco tiempo era incluso
mejor que el sexo oral
bueno para la misma época
aproximadamente
adentro en la cuarta ola del feminismo
vivir la revolución de los juguetes
sexuales escuchaba como influencers de
todo el mundo hablaban sobre la
masturbación femenina
y me acostaba con personas
y no me sentía mal por hacerlo
hemos vivido mucho tiempo sometidas y
ahora es nuestro momento y si en parte
era cierto pero no entendía por qué me
seguía sintiendo vacía
y adoraba el discurso feminista pero en
lo referente al sexo se seguía
reduciendo a la inmediatez la
individualidad la competitividad e
incluso el capitalismo
decían que podíamos hacer lo que
quisiéramos pero seguíamos manteniendo
las mismas conductas al final eran ellos
los que daban el primer paso y yo me
hacía de rogar
y en todo este proceso de repente
pregunté
oye
y qué pasa con los hombres
y me dijeron ellos ya están empoderados
seguro
empoderados o adoctrinados
charlé con varios hombres y me di cuenta
de la losa increíble que tienen sobre
sus hombros con referencia al sexo
el tamaño la erección la eyaculación el
rendimiento leer las señales conocer las
zonas erógenas y un largo etcétera
me dijeron que era el momento de la
sexualidad femenina y sí es cierto
porque nuestro placer ha estado siempre
en un segundo plano pero ahora mismo
cuántas veces hemos escuchado que se
reivindica el punto p frente al punto g
igual clítoris
cuántas veces vemos que una persona con
pene enseña sus masturbadores por redes
sociales siempre a cuántas veces lo
vemos de una persona con vulva
cuántas veces hemos visto a un hombre
hablar sobre sus inseguridades sexuales
frente cuántas veces lo hemos visto de
una mujer
no os preocupéis porque aquí la balanza
cambia porque cuantas fotos de pene se
envían no solicitadas a través de las
redes sociales frente a cuantas fotos de
vulva se envían
en fin todo esto fue un antes y un
después en mí
y de repente me di cuenta
que el sexo a día de hoy todavía sigue
siendo un tabú en nuestra sociedad y no
entendía por qué
hasta que me di cuenta que era un arma
de revolución masiva
y que lo estábamos haciendo mal el sexo
no tenemos que normalizar lo tenemos que
naturalizar lo porque lo normal se rige
por una aceptación social y lo social
está delimitado por una estructura y
unas normas mientras que lo natural no
es cuestionable porque forma parte de
nuestra esencia
en este proceso también me di cuenta que
como mujer estaba mitificada formaba
parte de un mito social
siempre tenía que oler bien
yr depilada es tan suave
nunca era suficiente y siempre era
demasiado o vas demasiado maquillada o
que te ha pasado en la cara hoy estás
enferma
o estás demasiado gorda o tienes que
comer un poco más no
me miraba en el espejo y me preguntaba
si estaba buena cuando lo importante es
que estoy viva
y que tengo un cuerpo y que gracias a él
puedo vivir experiencias y sentir
sensaciones
y da igual todo lo demás únicamente por
eso se lo tengo que agradecer además en
qué momento aceptamos que los
estereotipos de belleza nos representan
porque yo no me acuerdo
en ese proceso también mi forma de vivir
antes vivía en lo que yo llamo la
intensidad vertical
básicamente un día estaba súper feliz y
al otro día estaba súper triste súper
feliz super triste y esta intensidad era
un pelín tóxica
y después está la intensidad horizontal
a mí el equilibrio me parecía aburrido
porque veía una línea constante
hasta que cambie la perspectiva y vi su
profundidad
y era infinita
así que cuando como como intensamente
cuando camino lo hago intensamente y
cuando follo follo intensamente porque
quiero profundizar en mí y ver mi
infinito
en ese momento me plantee
qué futuro quería en el sexo sin duda
quería que fuera de una forma más
consciente porque la conciencia es la
enemiga de la manipulación
deje de masturbarme con los cuerpos y
empecé a mirar a saborear a tocar a oler
a sentir
porque respetaba el cuerpo que tenía
delante y porque quería que respetaran
el mío
des programe mi mente
ahora
si me acostumbro a una técnica sexual la
cambio se lo pongo difícil al cerebro
porque no quiero depender de un
succionador de clítoris o de una forma
específica de masturbarme para sentir
placer
y sobre todo
aprendí a comunicarme
si quiero algo
los digo porque por lo general
las personas no son videntes
me plantee también cómo quería que fuese
mi futuro en el amor
descubrí el poliamor y me di cuenta que
era mi modelo relacional pero no porque
estuviera de moda o porque fuese mejor o
peor que la monogamia no es ni mejor ni
peor es simplemente una alternativa y
esa alternativa se adapta más a mí y a
mi forma de entender las relaciones y el
amor
añadí también cinco ingredientes a mis
relaciones la empatía
la comunicación la confianza el respeto
y el amor
e incluso podríamos añadir un sexto que
sería la responsabilidad afectiva
y me aleje
del amor romántico tóxico de las medias
naranjas de positivizar los celos y las
posesiones de fusionar me con otra
persona o de depender emocionalmente de
esa persona
y busque el equilibrio
el crecimiento
y la aportación mutua
pero en todo este proceso de lo que me
di cuenta es de quién había detrás
tras el adoctrinamiento social existe el
interés de que el sistema se mantenga de
preservar la hegemonía de seguir con la
individualidad
de que sigamos siendo manipulables
pero vi que la pirámide se sostiene por
la base
y yo ya no quería llegar a la cima
quería y quiero actuar en colectivo
porque si los cimientos tiemblan el
sistema cae
a tuyo del futuro le digo
plantéate para qué vives
pero sobre todo plantea que para quien
lo estás haciendo el sexo ha sido y es
la herramienta más censurada hasta el
momento
pregúntate por qué
y ya puestos a preguntar pregúntate
quién eres
eres
porque el futuro está en pie más
presente que nunca
no dejes que nadie te lo quite recuerda
que solamente vas a vivir una vez
de ti depende
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]